そうってじゃあず社長です皆さん椅子ってそーりますです他パーフィストカス2分椅子
とか
玉座とか色々な意思があると思うんですけど皆さん改定とルイス付きでございますか
座ってクルクル回転する椅子があるんですけども合計回転する is
大好きなんでしょなんでかわかんないんですけど改善している異性に無限の可能性を
感じておりましてあの回転車ルイスの回転率を
どこまでた構えでいるのかなと思って4色はなんか子供の頃だが試したわけですよ
人力で個性ファンってマジでめっちゃ速くしたり何回で椅子に座ってこうめっちゃ
自分で回転してめっちゃ気持ち悪くなるのはなんか
楽しんだりしている
子供の頃の僕が言いましたとりあえずなかなかいてリースに座って回転することになん
か変な美学を冠っているんですよ
でもやっぱり回転数を変えているをあげるって難しいんですよ伊勢ってさも台が付い
てるんでバランスが取れにくい
なかなかにごきれいに重心を捉えて回転することが難しいねああ
なかなか採点制のスピード速くするの難しいなと思っているんですけどその中何かお礼
とんでもないず見つけてしまいましたこちらながら多くこれ待ってイスカのこんなとし
ながら座ってなんか運動するみたいなやつなんですけども改訂したんですよ猫だって
いうことは4つだけだしてみますわご覧ください
完全に5ですってことでこれを超えておいてマジます
おっ
なんか書いてる悪くないかドンキ熱もっとハイでしたよ
[音楽]
はぁっはぁっはぁっ
re ん
まあ
そもそも回転しますねこそじゃこんなに回転力を出そうとしてもやっぱりあったとして
もこれぐらいのスピード感でしか回らないんですよこれで改善すれば一番いいんですよ
ねこうやってうわぁ
を再生率を最大に高めるアイテムがこちらダーデンドリーこれ一間はしたらどんどん
ネガティブアイス食ってるんじゃないかと思いますちょっとてよ
と思いますツイ2わー
をまずやばいこれ
これやべさフォアを持ってユーザー
[音楽]
すごいまだまでなんかねもうちょっとあげる日やつですよね
早すぎる強くないなく重心がた空が空得られないですね
ええええええ
noa
[音楽]
いやーようには3問フロントに打ってもに剃ればいいでしょ
いやあああこれから
数回最速の解決にスワロブラー
[音楽]
シガー
ティガーも最高速の時に乗りますから果たして
市場たい時の回転数は座ってる人にどのような影響があるのでしょうか
以来
[音楽]
ああああああ
まったりじゃないん
me
dea
teal
car
rar ああああああああ
[音楽]
はいはい号